This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Let's go back to the Soviet Union in the 1950s. There was a terrible hunger for anything that came from West. Anything at all. Doesn't matter what. This is Alexander Jenis, Russian writer and broadcaster. For example, lighter. Can you imagine how important it was lighter? American lighter was like treasure. But a lighter is just a lighter. During the Cold War, what many Russians really craved were
这里是“99%无形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。让我们回到20世纪50年代的苏联。当时人们对来自西方的任何东西都充满了极度的渴望。任何东西都可以。什么都行。这是亚历山大·杰尼斯，俄罗斯作家兼广播员。比如打火机。你能想象一个打火机有多重要吗？美国打火机就像是宝藏。但打火机终究只是打火机。在冷战期间，许多俄罗斯人真正渴望的是
expressions of creativity and art, much of which came from the West. They wanted Western music. There was of course American Western music. Western music was incredible and important. They were crazy about jazz and rock and roll. Of course, Elvis Presley. Oh, so much art and music. There's crap. You still have money. And it was extremely hard to smuggle in vinyl records that were made in the West.
对创造力和艺术的表达，其中大部分来自西方。他们想要西方的音乐。当然有美国西部音乐。西部音乐令人难以置信且至关重要。他们对爵士乐和摇滚乐疯狂着迷。当然还有埃尔维斯·普雷斯利。哦，有那么多的艺术和音乐。还有垃圾。你依然有钱。而且，走私在西方制作的黑胶唱片是极其困难的。
And if a prized album did make it in, ordinary Russians couldn't make copies to sell or trade to their fellow comrades because vinyl, the material itself, was impossibly expensive in scarce. So we didn't have any records, it was, I didn't even see records, I think, in my life Western record, because it was dangerous. Soviet censorship was endless, but so was Russian ingenuity. That's Davy Anelsen, she and Nikki Silva are the kitchen sisters, and they produce the radiotopia podcast Fugitive Waves.
如果一张珍贵的专辑真的被带进来了，普通的俄罗斯人也无法制作副本来出售或与同胞交换，因为黑胶材料本身稀缺且贵得离谱。所以我们没有任何唱片，我甚至觉得我在有生之年都没见过西方的黑胶唱片，因为这很危险。苏联的审查制度无休无止，但俄罗斯人的聪明才智也是如此。这是戴维·阿内尔森，她和妮基·西尔瓦是“厨房姐妹”，她们制作了Radiotopia播客《逃亡浪潮》。
So the dissident music counterculture produced bootleg records on anything they could get their hands on. Before the tape recorders, they used X-ray film of your bones. They used used X-ray film of your bones. This is Sergey Khrushchev. And they tape on this, the music from the United States or from Europe. So it was musica nakastya, music on the bones. Music on the bone, rock on ribs, rib rock, skeleton music, bone records.
因此，持不同政见的音乐反文化运动用他们能弄到的任何材料制作盗版唱片。在磁带录音机出现之前，他们用的是你骨头的X光片。他们用的是你骨头的X光片。这是谢尔盖·赫鲁晓夫。他们把来自美国或欧洲的音乐录制在上面。所以这就是“骨头音乐”，骨头上的音乐，肋骨上的摇滚，骨架音乐，骨头唱片。
Yes, that Khrushchev. My father was Nikita Khrushchev, the head of the Soviet Union. From 1953 to 1964, it was beginning of all this American music then. Just twist, rock and roll, everything coming there, they didn't broadcast it from the official radio. The kitchen sisters first learned of bone music records when they interviewed Sergei Krushchev about the disnant activity taking place in
是的，就是那个赫鲁晓夫。我的父亲是尼基塔·赫鲁晓夫，苏联的最高领导人。从1953年到1964年，那是所有这些美国音乐开始涌入的时期。扭扭舞、摇滚乐，所有东西都在涌进来，官方电台不播放这些。“厨房姐妹”最初是在采访谢尔盖·赫鲁晓夫关于在
people's tiny kitchens and the new Krushchev apartments that his father had built in the 1960s. These private kitchens became the hot spots of the culture, the place to gather for the free expression of ideas. With the KGB lurking almost everywhere and nearly every phone line bugged, these individual kitchens made it possible for friends to gather privately and speak their minds. With vodka flowing and pickles and herring piled high on the tables, these dissident kitchens became unofficial lecture halls, nightclubs, art galleries, bars, dating services. The place where politics were debated for been music was played, an underground art and literature circulated. It was
人们狭小的厨房以及他父亲在20世纪60年代建造的新赫鲁晓夫楼里进行的地下活动时，了解到骨头音乐唱片的。这些私人厨房成为了这种文化的聚集地，是自由表达思想的场所。在克格勃几乎无处不在、几乎每部电话都被监听的情况下，这些独立的厨房使得朋友们能够私下聚会并说出他们的真实想法。伴随着流淌的伏特加以及堆满桌子的泡菜和鲱鱼，这些持不同政见的厨房成为了非官方的演讲厅、夜总会、艺术画廊、酒吧、交友中心。这里是辩论政治、播放被禁音乐、流传地下艺术和文学的地方。当时
amazing the lengths people went to to share unsensored culture and politics. The risks they took to see a forbidden painting read a banned book or listen to a song. Music on bones is the legal production of records on exposed X-ray film. This is Exynia Vituleva. She's a visiting professor at Columbia in the Music on bones is the legal production of records on exposed extra film. This is Exynia Vituleva, she's a visiting professor at Columbia in the Department of History and Theory of Architecture. And it was a dissident practice in the USSR, primarily during the Cold War. The first studio which produced records on the ribs was a golden dog named in tribute to nipper rca victors famous dog logo golden dog the golden dog gang
人们为了分享未经审查的文化和政治，所付出的努力令人惊叹。为了看一幅被禁的画作、读一本被禁的书或听一首歌，他们甘愿冒生命危险。“骨头上的音乐”是将唱片非法制作在曝光的X光片上。这是叶夫根尼娅·维图列娃。她是哥伦比亚大学建筑历史与理论系的客座教授。“骨头上的音乐”是将唱片非法制作在曝光的X光片上。这是叶夫根尼娅·维图列娃，她是哥伦比亚大学建筑历史与理论系的客座教授。这是苏联时期的一种异见做法，主要发生在冷战期间。第一个在肋骨上制作唱片的录音室是一个名叫“金狗”的组织，这是向RCA胜利狗著名的狗标致敬。金狗帮
russlam baga slovskim was engineer got it idea to use old x ray buga slovskie reverse engineered a record duplication machine that a friend of his and brought from the west and put it to work. Raw vinyl plastic and other durable materials to make records was basically non-existent. So Bukus Lovsky tried to use whatever was available to scratch out copies of the records that were smuggled in. Coded paper was the most common source material on which to print copies, but those records only lasted a few plays on a turntable.
鲁斯兰·巴加洛夫斯基是一名工程师，他想出了使用旧X光片的点子。巴加洛夫斯基逆向工程了一台他朋友从西方带回来的唱片复制机，并将其投入使用。用于制作唱片的生乙烯塑料和其他耐用材料基本上是不存在的。因此，巴加洛夫斯基尝试使用任何可用的东西来刻录被走私进来的唱片副本。镀膜纸是用来打印副本最常见的原材料，但这些唱片在电唱机上只能播放几次。
Bootlegs could only make a big impact in the black market if they were more durable than at higher fidelity. That's when he thought of using discarded X-rays. Taken from the hospital trash and magical archives in order to make a kind of phonographic recording, my copy of a Western I-Nale record. But to talk only about the ingenuity of bone records doesn't really do them justice.
如果黑市上的盗版唱片比原版更耐用且音质更高，它们才能产生巨大的影响。就在那时，他想到了使用废弃的X光片。从医院垃圾和医疗档案中收集来，以便制作某种留声机录音，即我的西方黑胶唱片复制品。但如果只谈论骨头唱片的独创性，就真的对它们不公平了。
They're ghostly, beautiful, haunting, transparent and just ever so slightly creepy. X-ray plates thicker than the ones we grew up with. Ribs, feet, tarsals, meta-tarsals, femurs, tumors, kidneys, all with a slight etching of circles of sounds scratched onto them. And you can see the rough edges of the craft, which reflects the level of hardship that was being overcome. These bone records came out of what Russian's called Tatiana Difitsit, total shortages of
它们幽灵般、美丽、迷人、透明，而且带有一丝诡异。X光片比我们这一代人成长时见到的要厚。肋骨、脚掌、跗骨、跖骨、股骨、肿瘤、肾脏，上面都隐约蚀刻着被刮擦出的声音圆圈。你可以看到工艺粗糙的边缘，这反映了当时人们所克服的艰难困苦。这些骨头唱片诞生于俄罗斯人所称的“物资极度匮乏”的时期，也就是绝对
absolutely everything. That's Oni Advan Bremsen, she's a food and culture writer. So they would take an X-ray, they would cut it, trim it the shape of a record. I'm looking on the very rough made circles of X-ray. You see how? And even the cut, because it's made with scissors. and you can see sently blues through the record you can see the X-ray of skull. It's like from Hamlet, right? These records were cut with the manicure scissors. Then with a cigarette they would burn the middle out, so you could actually play it.
一切都极度短缺。这是安雅·冯·布雷姆森，她是一名美食和文化作家。所以他们会拿一张X光片，把它剪裁成唱片的形状。我正在看这些非常粗糙的X光片圆圈。你看，甚至连剪裁都是用剪刀完成的。你可以透过唱片看到隐隐的蓝色，能看到头骨的X光片。就像《哈姆雷特》里的场景一样，对吧？这些唱片是用修指甲的小剪刀剪出来的。然后用香烟烧掉中间的孔，这样你就可以实际播放它了。
These strange homemade creations were eventually put on the black market of course. It was a shadow industry like Unshining, it was a pop culture of Unshining. My brother, he got this X-ray record on the video. Love me Thunder, it was his most precious thing in his life. Валчу ромуншайник. В моих бразах, он угрозал эксорей-рекорд в Випа. Лав-митендер. Это он most precious thing in his life. Экспортный рекорд был очень, очень экспортно. Ты должны сыграть, как викли-соу. Встречу, как три батальзовутка.
这些奇怪的自制作品最终当然流向了黑市。这是一个像“无光”一样的地下产业，“无光”时期的流行文化。我哥哥弄到了这张X光片唱片。是猫王的《爱我温柔》，这是他生命中最珍贵的东西。……（俄语原声及翻译片段）。
И все это было, вовсом, вовсом, вовсом. Все. Они были в салоне, в салоне, в кафе, в салоне. Ты не можешь встать, что ты вебил, right? They were sold in underground cafes under the table. You can never check what you buy, right? Because it's darkly, they give you something and they promise that it is always press-legged, but you don't know, right? And you can't complain because you never meet these people again. I remember the first one I heard was Chubby Checkers.
这些唱片都是在地下咖啡馆的桌子底下出售的。你永远无法检查你买的是什么，对吧？因为光线很暗，他们给你一些东西并承诺这绝对是正版压制的，但你并不知道，对吧？而且你无法抱怨，因为你再也见不到这些人了。我记得我听的第一张是查比·切克的歌。
That's Gregory Frieden, Professor Emeritus of Slavic Languages and Literature at Stanford. When I became a teenager myself, I used to go and shop for them. The black market was opposite the official Soviet records to a melodia. Right the center of Moscow. It was a courtyard where they were young men, long overcodes. You would walk up to them and you ask them what they had and they would open the overcrowded and say this is Chevy Checkers and this is our expressly and this is Twist. They had the whole catalog, the whole display cases on the inside of the elbow code.
这是格雷戈里·弗里登，斯坦福大学斯拉夫语言与文学系荣休教授。当我成为一个少年时，我也经常去买它们。黑市就在官方苏联唱片店“旋律”的对面。就在莫斯科市中心。那是一个庭院，里面有许多穿着长大大衣的年轻男子。你会走到他们面前，问他们有什么，然后他们会敞开大衣说，这是查比·切克的，这是猫王的，这是扭扭舞的。他们拥有整个目录，整个展示柜都在大衣的里面。
It's pretty easy to look back on this practice and find it to be light, some verse of fun, but this was serious business. There was an official music patrol initiated by the KGB. To track the production of this anti-USSAR activity, punishments could be extreme. People making and buying bone records were always looking over their shoulders. In the 50s, the owners of this recording studio
回顾这段历史，很容易觉得这只是一种轻松的恶作剧或者好玩的事情，但这是一项严肃的业务。克格勃发起了一项官方音乐巡逻队。为了追踪这种反苏联活动的制作，惩罚可能是极其严厉的。制作和购买骨头唱片的人总是提心吊胆。在50年代，这家录音室的主人
got arrested for spreading Western propaganda. Moscow, UPI, a Russian vice squad, uncovered a clandestine record company recording Western style music in a vast underground studio in Leningrad. The report set official shutdown the operation, which had pressed records on the Golden Dog label for big profits. You could get three to five years for illegally copying music. The X-ray innovator himself, Ruflan Bugslowski, was sentenced to five years prison in Siberia. But cracking down on the pirates,
因传播西方宣传而被捕。莫斯科美联社报道，一个俄罗斯反腐败警察分队在列宁格勒的一个巨大地下录音室里破获了一家秘密唱片公司，该公司正在录制西方风格的音乐。报道称官方关闭了该行动，该行动一直在“金狗”厂牌下压制唱片以获取巨额利润。非法复制音乐可能会被判处三到五年监禁。X光革新者鲁斯兰·巴加洛夫斯基自己也被判处在西伯利亚服刑五年。但打击盗版商、
copying the disc wasn't the only way the state was combating the scourge of bone records. They pirated the pirates. The Soviet government attempted to flood the market of bone records by creating unplayable records in an effort to kill the demand. They would either make records that would physically mess with players, or they would include vocal recording in the middle of the music, saying things like, you like rock and roll,
复制光盘并不是国家打击骨头唱片瘟疫的唯一手段。他们对盗版商进行了“盗版”。苏联政府试图通过制造无法播放的唱片来充斥骨头唱片市场，以此消灭需求。他们要么制造会在物理上损坏播放器的唱片，要么在音乐中间加入人声录音，说诸如“你喜欢摇滚乐吗”，
you anti-soviet slime. This is chick to chick. She, how is Russian translation. You could easily identify them because they were no labels. So you say, OK, this is, you know, antrauses. Lungs, and that means Elvis, and this is, you know, Dad's. Brandt Jomer, and that means Duke Ellington. These exposed X-rays became the new form of secret and precious information.
“你这个反苏渣滓”。这是《脸贴脸》。她，俄语翻译是怎么样的。你可以很容易地识别它们，因为它们没有标签。所以你会说，好吧，这是肺，这意味着猫王，这是大卫，这意味着杜克·艾灵顿。这些曝光的X光片成为了秘密且珍贵信息的新形式。
The Western Heats recorded on the interiors of Soviet citizens. Bone Music There's a collaboration between the kitchen sisters and 99% invisible. You can hear more about bone music and the X-ray records that Jack White and Gibby Haynes made for third-man records on the Kitchen Sisters podcast that's called Fugitive Waves. Subscribe today. The Kitchen Sisters are Nikki Silva and Davie Nelson, with help from Brandy Howell, Andrew Roth, and Nathan Dalton. 99% invisible is Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle, Avery Truffman, Kurt Colstad, and me Roman Mars.
西方热门金曲被录制在苏联公民的身体内部。“骨头音乐”是“厨房姐妹”与“99%无形”的合作项目。你可以在“厨房姐妹”名为《逃亡浪潮》的播客中听到更多关于骨头音乐以及杰克·怀特和吉比·海恩斯为第三人称唱片公司制作的X光唱片的故事。今天就订阅吧。“厨房姐妹”是妮基·西尔瓦和戴维·阿内尔森，并得到了布兰迪·豪尔、安德鲁·罗斯和内森·多尔顿的帮助。“99%无形”团队包括萨姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、库尔特·科尔斯塔德以及我罗曼·马尔斯。
We are a project of 91.7K ALW San Francisco and produced under the offices of ArcSign, in our architecture and interiors firm, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. All of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story, including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible, you must go to 99pi.org Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的项目，并在位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的建筑与室内设计事务所ArcSign的主持下制作。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞本节目。我们所有人都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，包括酷炫的照片和链接，并收听“99%无形”的所有单集，你必须访问99pi.org Radio Tapio。来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。